Kip Cobb wolve a would Miriam will soon
face his first great step on the road to
priesthood he hopes to take part in the
most important ceremony of the Ethiopian
Orthodox Church Tim cat the Feast of the
Epiphany celebrating the baptism of
Christ
although epiphany is celebrated
throughout the Christian world the
Ethiopian Tim cat ceremony is different
it features sacred replicas of the Ark
of the Covenant to be allowed to take
part
Kip Cobb must convince the senior
priests of his church that he has total
commitment to his calling complete faith
[Music]
for six years Kip cop has not been ready
to take part in team captain if the
elders question his faith now it may be
many years before he'll be considered
again and this is not the only pressure
on Kipp cop he's got a family tradition
to live up to yeah wonder to me any god
I am I'm one of three brothers the other
two have finished their religious
education they are already working in
the church I'm the youngest but I want
to achieve the same as that man hip hop
practice is a form of Christianity that
is both ancient and unique to Ethiopia
[Music]
his life revolves around worship and
study at a church school in Lalibela his
teacher his own father will be one of
those who have the final say as to
whether he's ready to take part in the
tail cat festival there's little formal
structure to give cobs education there's
no end of year exam and study is
constant learning the Scriptures by
heart is in itself a monumental task but
Kip pub has to learn them in PS which
died out as an everyday language around
a thousand years ago
[Music]
Kip Cobb lives with ten other students
they earn their meals the traditional
way by begging for food enduring
physical hardship is seen as a necessary
step and Kip of spiritual development
so is learning to accept charity
especially from villagers who often have
little food to spare
fortunately the people around lalibela
are devout Christians who will give
whatever they can in exchange for a
blessing there are few sites more
impressive in the city of Lalibela Kip
Cobbs Church is one of 11 churches each
cut straight into the volcanic rock they
were built by the 12th century King
Lalibela who had a vision of the holy
city of Jerusalem Kip Cobbs long months
of prayer and study have been rewarded
he's been chosen to be a part of the Tim
Katt ceremony it is an auspicious
landmark in his spiritual development
but it is also a deeply private moment a
moment of personal revelation Christians
from all over Ethiopia come to the
ancient city of Lalibela for the
festival of Tim cat hoping for a glimpse
of the replicas of the Ark of the
Covenant known as Tavis
to come close to the Tabet is to come
close to the Word of God itself the
tablets of the eleven churches of
lalibela emerge carried on the heads of
the most senior priests they are
considered so sacred that no one is ever
permitted to gaze upon them and must
remain completely covered from the
labyrinths they form a procession and
make their way to the baptism pool
scenes like this were described in the
Bible when the Israelites welcomed Moses
returned from Mount Sinai with the Ten
Commandments
[Music]
celebrating the baptism of Christ the
faithful are themselves
[Music]
kid Kyle has taken his first step on a
great
spiritual journey
[Music]